so
growing up with a uh a d.a as a father
and your
dad's a d.a your mom's a judge right she
was a judge um she's now a mediator but
she was um the judge who put o.j in
prison in las vegas judge edo
people are like your mom's judge edo i'm
like no
but is growing up with like a da as a
father is like the same thing as like
being a preacher's daughter
do you get in trouble i mean would my
dad answer the door with a shotgun no um
it's i guess it would be
i guess i you would have to ask the men
who have tried to date me i don't know i
i it probably is intimidating i don't
think that that's the question more
think he's saying like that are you wild
like a catholic school oh oh oh see i'm
jewish so i didn't get the joke um but
you grew up in vegas i mean were you
going i was definitely
you know i was like
i definitely
was a rambunctious kid i was a hyper kid
i had adhd as a kid i was diagnosed from
a very young age so um i played sports
like and i was always getting in trouble
in the principal's office like i went to
um religious schools
um i went to a christian school in vegas
and i think that's how my mom tried to
like curb
my
you know wildness or at least prevent
because i didn't do i wasn't like
drinking or doing drugs but
you know i would sneak out of the house
and
when when did you become such a pothead
you know it wasn't until i got to
college um
because you know i i had taken a lot of
pharmaceuticals
um you know i was diagnosed with
depression when i was 12
and from a very young age had taken
pharmaceuticals for a lot of my mental
health you know
like ritalin and i was on adderall
i started on adderall when i was five
wow did you ever snored it when you were
five
although if i did i would have been the
coolest kid for sure um but i uh
did it work like
it makes everybody else hyper and stay
awake you know how many businesses i had
when i was five years old
is that like what the deal is with adhd
yeah i was able to focus like at five i
felt like you know um
yeah i could conquer the world but i'm
on legal
meth so yeah um yeah doing blow back in
the day like really like made me like
recluse and like inward i didn't get
hyper i mean i got hyper but like i just
i think that would be the same effect as
adhd medicaid like ritalin would make me
like real like
i was very serious i would be it would
make me very irritable
um but i was i would hyper focus on
whatever they wanted me to focus on yeah
so yeah so when i was 19 i went away to
college and a boyfriend of mine smoked
weed
and i was still on pharmaceuticals at
the time
and i i tried it and i remember liking
the way it made me feel it just made me
feel
i don't know better
so
and then did you stop the medication or
do you still continue eventually i came
off the pharmaceuticals i was 23 when i
came off
and did that suck
um it wasn't
like it wasn't as bad as it could have
been because i did it with the advice of
a doctor i was like how do i taper down
um with support and i wanted everyone to
know like i did it the way that you're
supposed to do it i'm like i'm not going
to just [__] around with this because if
certain medications that i was on if you
come off you can have a seizure
um certain medications i was on if you
don't take it the right way you can
develop a deadly rash i mean this stuff
is gnarly um so yeah and i i came off
and i've been off since i was 20
um three years old i believe
wow or sorry i was excuse me i was 26
i believe yeah
all right i think that clip was awesome
but not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what i've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions which
is out september 27th and if you
pre-order it right now you can get the
autographed copy so get on it man
pre-order my book it's not going to
waste your time because i'm proven dude
new york times bestseller my first
book's five star rated on amazon and i
have no doubt this one will be too so
get the autographed copy right now
by pre-ordering it at stevo.com
yeah dude